You are probably familiar with magnetic resonance
imaging machines, either through the claustrophobic
sensation of being inside one or from seeing
the incredibly high detail cross sections
of the human body they provide.
.
MRIs have completely changed how we view and
understand our bodies.
It has never been easier to visualize organs
with such high details.
We can safely locate and identify tumors in
the kidneys, brain, stomach, and pancreas.
We can inject paramagnetic contrast agents
into the bloodstream to locate blockages in
the heart, allowing doctors to accurately
implant life-saving stents to open blood vessels.
A tiny keyhole surgery that patients can recover
from quickly, where once dangerous open heart
surgery was the only option.
Magnetic resonance imaging has truly changed
the nature of medical diagnosis and treatment.
A technology that seems straight out of a
sci-fi novel, how they work is a complete
mystery to most.
To unlock the power of this machine physicists
and engineers first had to discover and master
the principles of quantum mechanics, superconducting
magnets, computer science, and mathematics.
The clean futuristic white facade of an MRI
machine hides a world of complicated and marvelous
engineering that you may not have ever considered.
Prior to their introduction to medicine, we
peered into our bodies using harmful ionizing
x-rays or low-detailed ultrasounds.
While incredibly useful, even to this day,
these two imaging techniques pale in performance
to the safe, millimeter resolution of MRIs.
Capable of creating a 3D reconstruction of
the body rather than a flat 2D image.
Achieving all of that without any moving parts.
Imaging in medicine relies on collecting signals
from the body based on the innate physical
properties of tissues.
Ultrasound imaging relies on how sound waves
bounce off tissues of different densities.
X-rays form images based on the absorption
of high-energy radiofrequency waves.
Magnetic resonance imaging, however, relies
on something far less intuitive, the quantum
properties of the hydrogen atom.
The human body is teeming with hydrogen atoms
located in water, carbohydrates, and proteins.
To image the body, MRI machines exploit a
quantum property of these hydrogen atoms.
A property called spin.
How it does this is a marvel of modern physics
and engineering.
Spin is an innate property of particles just
like mass and charge.
Spin makes particles behave like tiny bar
magnets.
The proton inside the hydrogen nucleus behaves
like a magnet.
The orientation of its magnetic north is described
probabilistically.
Under normal circumstances, this probability
is evenly distributed.
This means that the combined magnetic field
of many hydrogen atoms cancels out.
But, this changes when the hydrogens are inserted
into a large external magnetic field just
like the ones MRIs create.
This changes the distribution of the tiny
magnets, augmenting the number of atoms aligned
with the external magnetic field.
This imbalance is the source of the MRI signal,
as we can manipulate these tiny magnets to
produce signals that can be processed into
images.[1]
Once the atoms are aligned in the machine's
incredibly strong magnetic field the machines
give them a tiny nudge using a magnetic radiofrequency
pulse.
This pulse comes from this set of coils inside
the machine that send pulses by simply applying
an alternating current through its coils at
a very specific frequency.
This nudge misaligns these hydrogen bar magnets
to shift their magnetic field perpendicular
to the large magnetic field the machine is
creating.
Naturally, the spins want to align their orientation
back to their original position, aligned with
the machine's magnetic field, but they don’t
fall back immeditely, they decay in a spiraling
motion.
This decay causes a changing magnetic field,
and by placing a coil of wire nearby, this
changing magnetic field can induce currents
that can be read as a clear signal.
MRI machines can use the same coils to send
the “nudge pulses” and to read the signal
from the body.
These coils are placed here, as close to the
patient as possible but still Inside the MRI
tube.
For higher contrast and resolution, some machines
use separate coils to transmit pulses and
receive the signal.
This allows the receiver coils like these
to be placed much closer to the body, maximizing
the strength of the signal.
[2]
We can increase the number of hydrogens, aligning
with the external magnetic field by increasing
the strength of the external magnetic field.
In turn, the hydrogen magnet can induce a
larger current as it spirals back.
So, by simply increasing the strength of the
MRIs field, we increase the strength of the
signal collected and therefore improve image
quality.
Common MRI field strengths are 1.5 to 3 tesla,
around 300,000 times stronger than the earth's
magnetic field and 30,000 times stronger than
your common fridge magnet. [3] You absolutely
do not want anything ferrous around these
machines during operation, a field this strong
can lift nearby wheelchairs straight off the
ground.
For research purposes, MRIS can produce even
higher magnetic fields, up to 20 teslas.
Achieving this intense magnetic field comes
as no easy feat.
Early MRIs used permanent magnets as their
source of the main magnetic field but only
reached strengths of 0.5T limiting the resolution
of the machine [4].
Electromagnets can be used to reach stronger
magnetic fields, but standard electromagnets
can’t produce a 1.5 tesla field.
Higher magnetic fields require higher electric
currents that would melt ordinary wires.
To achieve larger currents in the wires, engineers
required superconducting coils. [4]
Superconductors are another sci-fi technology.
Temperature affects all metallic conductors.
With resistance gradually lowering with temperature.
But superconducting materials are special,
in that their resistance drops to zero at
temperatures close to minus 273 degrees Celsius,
or absolute zero.
In theory, when this happens, an electric
current could travel in a loop of superconducting
material indefinitely, never needing a power
source.
In reality, this means that the main superconducting
coil in MRIs does not consume any power directly.
Rather, the main consumption of energy is
just to keep the coil cooled down so the current
will travel endlessly, leaving the MRI magnet
permanently on.
The energy needed to run an MRI for a full
year is equivalent to 25 four-person households,
around 130,000 to 140,000 kWh per year.
[5]
The most common superconducting material used
in MRIs is Niobium–titanium.
[6].
The demand for High-resolution images is so
large that 80% of all the Nb-Ti we extract
from the earth goes into an MRI machine [7].
To achieve the incredibly low temperatures
needed for superconductivity, we need a very
cold refrigerant.
Early MRI machines used to submerge their
superconducting wires in a bath of liquid
Helium.
Pouring one thousand (1000) liters of liquid
helium, at minus 269 degrees celsius, into
the machine to cool the superconducting coil
as close to absolute zero as possible.
This evaporated the helium, allowing it to
escape the machine as a gas.
Meaning, early MRI machines required regular
refillings of liquid helium.[8]
Even though helium is an incredibly common
gas in the universe, it is so light that it
can escape our atmosphere into space.
We extract helium from underground gas caverns,
where it accumulated as a byproduct of uranium
and thorium radioactive decay.
But once we allow that helium to escape into
the atmosphere, it is gone for good.
Floating to the top of our atmosphere and
gradually being blown into space by solar
winds.
We will eventually run out of natural helium.
This method of cooling was costly and unsustainable,
costing up to $26,000 per year in helium refills.[9]
To avoid this refilling problem, modern MRI
machines use a vacuum-sealed chamber that
holds the liquid helium without letting it
evaporate.
This eliminates the need for refilling and
minimizes the cost of operation.
These so-called “Zero Boil off” machines
are now the norm in MRI technology.
They use an electric refrigerant cycle like
the one in your fridge but on steroids.
This cycle keeps the helium in its liquid
phase and keeps the magnets cool enough to
maintain them in their superconducting state
[8].
Now that we know why and how the hydrogen
atoms are aligned, we need a way to turn that
information into an image, and to do that
we need to know the physical location of the
hydrogen atoms.
Recall that MRIs detect signals from the spiral
decay pattern of hydrogen atoms after they
have been “nudged”.
These spirals decay with a unique rotational
frequency (⍵),. interestingly, this is the
only frequency that can “nudge” the hydrogen
atoms too.
Luckily, rotational frequency is dependent
on something we control, the magnetic field
strength.
For example, hydrogen resonates at 64 MHz
at 1.5 Tesla and at 128 MHz at 3 tesla[10].This
means the atoms in a weaker magnetic field
will rotate slower while atoms in a stronger
field will rotate faster.
To nudge these atoms we need a radiofrequency
wave at 64 MHz or 128 MHz.
We can use this to our advantage to image
individual slices.
If we can apply a gradient to the magnetic
field strength, we can selectively nudge atoms
along the gradient by applying the corresponding
frequency.
This gradient is applied precisely using a
separate set of regular electromagnets, aptly
named gradient coils.
To image a slice near the weaker end of the
tube, the machine sends a “nudging pulse”
centered at a lower rotational frequency say
63.998 MHz and to image a slice on the other
side of the tube the pulse is centered at
64.002MHz.
This still feels like magic.
It’s not terribly obvious how detecting
the decay from these spiraling hydrogen atoms
can create images.
The receiving coil can only measure the sum
of all these spiraling decays.
We need a way of processing the signal to
create an image.
Let's start by understanding how to get contrast
between tissues before delving deeper into
the techniques used to actually form images.
We need a way of identifying different kinds
of tissues to form an image, to do that we
need to contrast the tissues using two different
signal types.
The first one deals with how quickly atoms
re-align themselves with the large magnetic
field after a nudging pulse.
This is called T1 relaxation.
The second measure comes from the physical
reality of interaction between hydrogens.
The atoms do not realign with the magnetic
field uniformly.
In tissue, hydrogens interact with each other
and with their surroundings.
Right after the nudging pulse is sent, the
small interactions cause the spins to fall
out of uniformity.
Since the coil can only measure the sum of
all these spiral decays, then the failing
out of order would create a decaying signal.
This is called T2 decay.
Importantly, the two rates are not equal,
and even more important they are dependent
on the tissue.
Hydrogens in fat have different intrinsic
characteristics and interactions than hydrogens
in water.
This difference is what lets technicians contrast
the tissues.[10]
We can emphasize the T1 signal by sending
pulses rapidly and listening to the signal
immediately, as the dephasing effects of T2
do not have enough time to take place.
We can emphasize T2 by sending pulses slowly
and listening for longer, allowing the dephasing
to occur.
[11]
Just like a photographer can play with camera
settings to take pictures of either the bright
sky or a dim environment.
MRI technicians can also play with two settings
to take images of contrasting tissues, the
time between pulse repetition, and how long
to wait to listen for a signal.
These two parameters are chosen by the technician
each time an MRI is performed and they choose
them depending on what the doctor would like
to image.[10]
For example, T1 is used to image fatty tissues
while suppressing the signal from water.
But maybe the doctor wants to assess the cerebral
spinal fluid in the spine or the brain, and
for that T2 signals are emphasized to enhance
the signal from water-based fluids.[12]
Remember, the signal is collected as a sum
from a singular slice, The machine needs to
form a 2D image of each slice.
There is one extra layer of complexity since
the receiver coil can only measure the sum
of the signals from all the decaying hydrogens
in the slice.
This is yet another story where old mathematics
discoveries guide modern technology.
In 1822 Joseph Fourier created a mathematical
framework that deconstructs complex waves
into simple additions of simpler waves.
This framework can be extended to 2D grayscale
geometries.
Just like a musical melody can be simplified
into additions of simpler notes.
Any image can be deconstructed into a weighted
average of simpler black and white stripes.
This is what MRIS uses to create images.
Instead of sampling individual pixels, MRIs
sample different striped patterns.
In reality, what does this mean for the spinning
hydrogens?
What is the physical representation of these
patterns?
It is easier if we imagine the slice as a
grid of rotating hydrogens where we color
the phase of the atoms in grey scale.
When rotating in unison the grid is all white.
Atoms rotating 180 degrees out of phase are
colored black.
MRIs exploit this to physically create the
striped patterns needed for the Fourier analysis.
Using another set of gradient coils MRIs precisely
change the phase of rotating hydrogens to
create striped patterns.
By controlling how long the Y and the X gradients
are turned on, the MRI can create patterns
in all directions and frequencies.
Slowly the machines start to imprint all the
patterns with different frequencies and orientations
to sample their relative strengths in physical
space.
And slowly by adding more and more patterns
the image starts to emerge.
This is what forms the image for each 2D slice.
Then the machine goes on to the next slice
of the body and starts the process all over
again.
Turning on and off coils inside a magnetic
field might sound familiar if you’ve ever
played with a speaker.
As basically they are the same things.
Gradient coils rapidly turning on and off
are the source of the loud clunking sounds
in MRIs.
MRIs are constantly evolving and the core
technology is starting to branch off.
Researchers want the highest resolution and
strive to increase the strength of the magnet,
while some hospitals and companies are making
them smaller and cheaper, as more practical
and cheap MRIS are incredibly useful in the
field.
[13]
It's hard to fathom the complexity of all
these systems, from superconducting wires
to vacuum-sealed helium reserves to rapidly
changing magnetic gradients, and even more
incredible to think of the first people who
figured out how to combine these technologies
together to peer into our bodies.
This intricate dance of quantum physics and
carefully manipulated gradients has allowed
MRIs to change the world of medicine.
The MRI machine is a truly astounding piece
of electronic technology.
Developing something this complicated requires
the very best test and measurement equipment.
Keysight puts the very best electronic measurement
and testing tools into engineers hands and
are holding another virtual event for engineers
and on May 16th.
This fantastic free event is a rare opportunity
to learn about electronics from experts.
This event will explore performance of batteries,
DC-DC converters and internet of things devices
using live experiments, like testing different
battery models at different temperatures to
see how that affects device run times and
testing DC-DC converter performance.
This isn’t just a live video you can watch
and learn from, there will be a live Q&A session
too, allowing you to ask industry experts
questions, an opportunity that does not come
around very often, and everyone that registers
for the event will be entered into a draw
for Keysight’s massive gear giveaway.
They are giving away 20 pieces of pro-grade
test gear worth 300,000 dollars.
These are extremely valuable professional
grade tools and you will get an extra entry
to the give away if you sign up with my link.
If you missed this event don’t worry, because
you can rewatch the stream and they will be
holding new live events every few months.
Whether you’re an expert engineer or electronics
newbie you should definitely be signing up
for this completely free event.